2020 on allait à oublier pour l'économie
avec le colis de 19 la france a connu
une récession historique à laquelle
l'état a répondu par le quoi qu'il en
coûte
de quoi limiter la casse pour l'instant
mais ces milliards d'argent public sont
ils une réponse pérenne à l'aggravation
du chômage
après tout notre économie était
peut-être déjà malade avant la pandémie
on va en parler tout de suite avec
l'économiste jacques sapir un bon soir à
jacques merci d'être avec nous au soir
se vanta alors jacques soit samantha et
quelle année donc 2020 pour l'économie
est ce qu'on peut comment fait en tirer
le bilan réellement oui on peut tout à
fait et c'est effectivement une année
extrêmement difficile l'économie
française comme d'ailleurs l'ensemble
des autres économies mais peut-être plus
particulièrement l'économie française a
été frappé de plein fouet par la crise
sanitaire
alors bien sûr le choc de cette crise a
été en partie atténuée par l'action de
l'état et vous avez tout à fait raison
de citer le quoi qu'il en coûte prononcé
par emmanuel macron dans son discours du
mois de mars
néanmoins il est très clair aussi que
certains secteurs ont été plus
particulièrement touchées et mettront
vraisemblablement des années à se
relever justement cette crise sanitaire
at elle été un choc aussi majeur qu'on
le prétend jacques oui absolument
absolument samantha on a connu pendant
l'année et 2020 un recul du pib donc du
produit intérieur brut entre -11 et -12%
c'est sans précédent même pendant la
crise de 1929
on n'avait pas eu un tel chiffre sur une
telle année maintenant ce qu'il faut
dire aussi et c'est un point important
et on va le voir justement sur ce
graphique c'est que en réalité la
croissance française et la consommation
avait arrêté de croître dès le troisième
voire le quatrième trimestre de l'année
donc ce qui est extrêmement frappant
aussi c'est le fait que cette crise
sanitaire elle n'est venu
frapper une économie qui n'allait pas
bien qui était déjà malade
alors est-ce que la france finalement
elle sentir plus mal que ses voisins on
peut le penser
on peut le penser effectivement samantha
si on regarde les chiffres comparatifs
on va voir que la france comme l'italie
sont des pays qui ont été plus
particulièrement frappé par cette crise
alors on sait que l'italie avait des
problèmes économiques extrêmement
important avant mais on voit que la
france et l'italie sont parmi les pays
qui ont le plus plongé inversement
l'allemagne s'en tire moins mal on ne
voit que nous sommes sous la moyenne de
la zone euro et l'ours qui est très
intéressant c'est de voir que les états
unis dont pourtant la gestion de la
crise sanitaire sont très très loin
d'être exemplaire on avait beaucoup de
critiques anodin le trump là dessus et
bien les états unis en fait s'en tire
nettement mieux que nous dans ces
conditions jacques or on imagine le
chômage il aurait dû exploser
oui effectivement
effectivement et ce qui a permis de
d'éviter que le chemin une explose pour
l'instant c'est bien entendu les mesures
de chômage partiel
ceci étant il faut voir si on regarde
les données de pôle emploi que
l'ensemble des catégories qui représente
le chômage réel c'est ce qu'on appelle
dans le langage de pôle emploi ou de la
dares les catégories à b et d et bien en
voix yann très nette pic au moment du
premier confinement par contre les
catégories c e qui représente les quasi
chômeurs diminue pourquoi parce que ils
ont été absorbés dans les catégories à b
et d
alors ce qui est très intéressant c'est
de voir que évidemment dans la période
qui va suivre le premier confinement il
ya une baisse
du nombre des véritables chômeurs mais
cette baisse ne fasse pas le pic du mois
d'avril
on voit que l'on va rester visiblement à
un niveau élevé et cela s'est bien
entendu sans les résultats du 2ème
confinement et sans évidemment l'effet
de l'arrêt du système de chômage partiel
qui se produira très probablement dans
les prochaines parle du chômage ac cela
nous amène aux jeunes directement
menacés les jeunes qui ont payé un lourd
tribut à la crise
oui oui c'est absolument évident les
jeunes ou si on appelle jeunes 10 ans
les demandeurs d'emploi entre 18 et 30
ans c'est vraiment la catégorie qui a
été le plus touché on le voit alors
c'est la catégorie qui est le plus
touché par le choc du confinement au
mois d'avril
c'est aussi la catégorie qui est
peut-être le plus aidé le plus sensible
justement aux mesures de chômage partiel
néanmoins avec non pas la femme est
disons la restriction du chômage partiel
après le premier confinement il ya on
voit que la courbe des demandeurs
d'emploi de 18 à 30 ans
remontez remonte de manière nettement
plus significative que par exemple pour
les 30 60 ans ne pour les 30-50 ans pour
les 51 65 ans donc les mesures prises
par l'état ont permis d'éviter le pire
oui ça il faut le dire le système du
chômage partiel a joué le rôle je dirais
d'un amortisseur extrêmement puissant
ceci étant ce qu'a fait la france n'est
pas en réalité différent de ce qu'on
fait de nombreux autres pays européens
il suffit de regarder par exemple sur
les sources du fonds monétaire
international
on voit que l'aide aux emplois c'est le
soutien aux emplois et qu'il a même
était plus important en proportion
évidemment en italie qu'il ne l'a été en
france alors ce qui est très intéressant
c'est de voir que en france avec la fin
du premier confinement il
tombe très vite alors que dans de
nombreux autres pays comme par exemple
l'italie l'allemagne voire la belgique
eh bien il va se maintenir dans la
période d'après le premier confinement
alors ces aides
jacques elle ne concerne pas tous les
emplois oui tout à fait et ça à samantha
il fait bien le préciser il ya la fois
les aides qui concerne évidemment les
salariés ce sont eux qui sont éligibles
au chômage partiel
et puis il ya les aides qui vont être
plutôt sur les travailleurs indépendants
et les auto entrepreneurs
alors là ce qui est intéressant c'est
que on a un mix et si vous voulez les
deux données qu'est ce qu'on voit on
voit là encore que l'italie fait à peu
près la même chose que nous nous ne
sommes réellement différent que par les
aides qui ont été attribuées aux
salariés aux dons aux employés pour ce
qui est des indépendants des pays que
l'italie l'allemagne
mais même par exemple l'espagne ont fait
nettement mieux que nous alors tout ça
évidemment à un coup oui oui bien sûr
bien sûr samantha c'est justement la
question du quoi qu'il en coûte bien sûr
cela aura un coût
et on sait déjà que normalement la dette
publique française qui étaient autour de
99 % à la fin de l'année dernière eh
bien elle va se situer à la fin 2020
entre 116 et 120 % donc oui ça a un coût
mais là encore il faut le souligner la
france n'a pas été le pays qui a le plus
aidé son économie à trois pays qui ont
aidé plus l'économie que nous et c'est
là encore c'est extrêmement intéressant
de voir l'italie qui a un système qui
est pas si différent du nôtre
l'allemagne et le royaume uni
le royaume uni qu'on présente très
souvent comme un modèle de société
libérale eh bien non et il a fait plus d
aides que la france en conclusion est ce
qu'on peut véritablement parler d'une
année noire
ah oui certainement
certainement et cette année je pense que
nous serons de très nombreux à vouloir
l'oublier a pour de très nombreuses
raisons les restrictions à la liberté
dans la vie quotidienne mais aussi pour
les questions économiques
maintenant il faut savoir que dans cette
année noire et bien certains secteurs
ont été beaucoup plus touchés que
d'autres
il ya évidemment le secteur de
l'aéronautique pas seulement le secteur
des transports aériens mais aussi le
secteur de la construction aéronautique
airbus est un très gros employeurs en
france après tout nous sommes le réel
père d'airbus il faut toujours le
rappeler
jusqu'au secteur du tourisme le secteur
du que du petit commerce a aussi été
très largement touchés je ne parle même
pas du secteur de la culture qui est
complètement sinistré oui effectivement
c'est une année qui a été extrêmement
difficile et la question de savoir
comment nous nous relèverons non pas en
2021 mais plutôt en 2022 en 2023 elle
est aujourd'hui posée oui c'est vrai
vous avez raison à jacques j'aimerais
pouvoir dire que ces tunnels est vite à
oublier n'est pas sûr effectivement
comme vous le dites que 2020 soit une
sinécure et bien bien sûr vous
reviendrez nous en parler l'année
prochaine à bientôt jacques merci